[Music]
a busy night for Democratic candidates
as they gathered with former president
Barack Obama he came to Las Vegas to
show support for the Nevada Democratic
candidates who are up for reelection
Victoria Saha joins us now live from
Cheyenne High School where a rally just
wrapped up Victoria
yeah this rally one of the last efforts
from the Democratic party to encourage a
voter turnout former president Barack
Obama not only encouraging people to go
out to vote but do it as soon as
possible
foreign it was a packed house with
voters coming out to see former
president Barack Obama who marched Las
Vegas as one of his key stops around the
country to encourage not only voting but
early voting because this election
requires every single one of us to do
our part both the former president and
Governor Steve sisalek touched one of
the biggest issues at the center of the
political Spectrum women's Reproductive
Rights my opponents is Extreme as he
gets he supports a ban on abortions
wants to ban contraceptives and you
deserve somebody's going to stand up for
a woman's right to make her own
decisions about her body and her health
care President Obama also focused on
other key issues this coming election
day including gas prices the need for
Affordable Health Care and housing the
former president and making it clear
that he wants Nevada Democrats to
continue fighting there may be a lot of
issues at stake in this election but the
basic question
that you should be asking yourself
is who will fight for you Senator
Catherine Cortez masto was also on hand
among other key Democrats audience
members also got a performance by artist
John Legend
now the spokesperson for Lombardo for
governor issuing this statement about
tonight's Democratic rally saying the
sad reality is that Steve sosolak would
rather campaign with Californians and
out-of-state politicians than fixing the
pressing issues facing Nevada closing
with nevadans are expected to elect
Sheriff Joe Lombardo and his new
leadership next week reporting live
tonight from Cheyenne High School
Victoria Saha 8 News Now